as a matter of fact I was so nervous if
there is no one in in this
room but oh amazing thank you for your
coming I'm SE the May of Soul before we
begin uh let's have some time for ice
breaking I prepare pop quides of our
soul of course we prepared some gifts
for the winner let's start okay the
first of our soul
629 it's a little difficult for your
information it is related to the history
of Soul okay historical landmarks
historical landmark oh I'm
sorry
okay here's that has been the capital
city of okay she is very
smart and last four
it's related to my political
[Laughter]
life okay
okay okay thank you I served four terms
for now okay thank you let's start the
lecture yeah it's enough ice breaking
yeah yeah as you can see here my
political life has been full of ups and
downs the green part two part is my
mayor's storm and the yellow part is my
political absence interesting to make a
long story short there is 10 years of
political absence between the two times
of mayor's town when I began my mayor's
town for the first time in
2006 I was focusing more on making so
more attractive but after 10 years of
absence you know I was doing my
volunteer work in Peru and Rwanda for
one year and I realized I had to do more
for the needy people you are looking at
the current vision of soul but today I'm
here to tell you how and what we do to
help the needy in Soul do you know Korea
is very famous for the Speedy Industrial
Iz ation and democratization this
picture shows us some symbolic aspect of
every Advanced country including Korea
the serious gap between the rich and the
poor the problem is the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer even more the
discrepancy becomes bigger and bigger
day by day Frankly Speaking the fact
that I was selected as Champion mayor
for inclusive growth by oecd recently
gave me such a rewarding feeling but at
the same time I was also surprised to
find out that oecd knew exactly what I
was doing as a matter of fact there are
so many policies for the needy people
but today I'd like to explain a few
major policies for the socially
neglected this is the first solution for
the polarization issue don't you think
the start line should be fair everyone
in this room knows the the importance of
Education in Korea however students need
to get extra help from the private
sector so-called krammers in Korean hak
one to go to better College this is the
main culprit of the big discrepancy
between the poor and Rich so it hit me
how can I help those poor students this
brought me to the the academic
assistance program called soul learn
this assistance program provides the
needy students with famous instructors
online lectures studying materials for
the free of for free of charge along
with Collegian mentors so we are trying
to increase the number of participants
for the program next year we've done it
a little over a year now and it has
produced fantastic results a total of
461 participants entered universities
through through this program this year I
strongly believe that if I can change
even one life through this program that
money is worth every penny and I will
not spare any money for doing it this
clip shows the effect of
[Music]
so
for
how do you feel about the clips it's
such a rewarding experience to me and I
know there is someone like this in this
room here comes the real deal for the
socially neglected it will change all
the current welfare system forever if
this safety income system becomes
successful all the current welfare
system you know might be Antiquated in
the current welfare system for the poor
even if you have opportunities to work
more and earn more you hesitate or you
can't work because the minute you work
more than the government's set limit you
will lose all the right to be aided so
in the current system people will not
want to work more and make more money
they would rather stay in the cycle of
being poor and not work anymore but in
the new welfare system system that I am
experimenting now people in the poor
boundary will want to work more and earn
more this is the comparison picture
between the current welfare system and
safety income system once they are
selected as help needed people we will
monitor how much they make every month
and supplement them with the money they
need if they don't make enough money and
we will stop giving them extra help if
they make enough enough money to leave
but even though they are not provided
with extra money because they worked
harder their status of getting help
doesn't change until they actually
graduate from it this kind of experiment
is very common in many countries many
cities including Soul this is the
outcome of the past one year of the new
system there is a picture of
professionals commenting on our
experiment now now let's talk about the
medical care system at this point in
time I think I need to say something
about Korea's Health Care system I can
dare to say that our system is far
better than
yours please don't kill me for
this in our current health care System
the richer pay more and the pter pay
less but the pter get far more medical
benefit from hospitals and and doctor's
offices even with all this benefit as
mayor of Soul I'm trying to build more
City hospitals for the people who are in
need of help this policy gives me
another Pride nowadays people do not
stop to death because our government is
taking such good care of them in terms
of food in my opinion at this point in
time we need to do something about their
will to survive on their own because
it's far far more important than the
food I've have tried to give those
homeless people the opportunity to take
some liberal arts related courses at
colleges Upon finishing the program they
will be treated the same way as ordinary
college graduate the same graduation
suit and the cap and everything else
believe it or not about 70% of pant in
the program survived the courses and
left the colleges with ever high PR
selfesteem yeah now let's take our
attention to the world you know we had a
horrible conflict with North Korea about
70 years ago if we hadn't received help
from the UN I wouldn't be standing here
and talking to you like this now we
can't forget the very much needed
enormous help from other countries at
the
time and we are the only country country
in the world that had help from the
world before and is giving the help back
to the world now this Aid money we gave
wasn't much in the beginning as you can
see but as of this year we are
increasing the amount of Aid money
dramatically and also at the same time
we are sending out more volunteers to
the world you know I'm one of those
Believers that it's far better to help
the need
by teaching them how to fish and not
just giving them a fish itself what a
coincidence the initials for knowledge
sharing program are the same as Korea
sharing program I hope this
transformation of Korea can give
inspiration and courage to many less
developed countries this is what we are
doing to help under developed countries
become more self-sufficient by growing
rise more productively this is possible
because Korea could develop easier
rights to breed to survive in destitute
African countries like Rwanda we are
making every effort to solve the
starvation issues in Africa by
developing new rice breed and it has
been very successful so far I myself
stayed in Rwanda for six months in
2014 at the time I helped the city
government of Kali with the with the
issues such as industrialization and
Welfare systems while I was there I was
able to witness a highly successful case
of growing rice more effectively in the
remote Village of musima in the new
Village movement so-called seile
movement in Korea about five volunteers
worked together as a group for a few
years these volunteers LED dramatic
changes in the mindset of the villagers
they took the initiative and set
examples for the villagers the locals
slowly but surely learned how to grow
rise and finally they realize the true
meaning of diligence self- a and
cooperation these three principles
diligence self- Aid and cooperation are
the spirits of the SE movement that were
the fundamentals of Korean development
on the other hand this is sharing
knowledge and experience of Soul we are
sharing our knowledge and experience
with 61 cities in 35 countries these are
various examples of sharing our best
practices around the
world according to the news quite a few
cities including the city of New York is
benchmarking our way of processing food
waste which is being turned into
fertilizers animal fees and sources of
energy in Soul you can pay for one low
price of public transportation and you
can take the Subway or buses as many
times as you want actually two weeks ago
I announced the new policy of unlimited
use of various Transportation Systems
including buses Subways and bicycles and
in one year River Bus for only $50 a
month by benchmarking Germany its name
is climate companion car
as you all know soul is a world famous
smart city with stronger infrastructure
ever now there's no question about that
and last year we launched the sole Smart
City prize so far 240 cities
corporations and organizations around
the world have applied for the prize and
shortly after I returned to Soul the
world city Summit mayor Forum will be
held to award the prize at last the this
is the last page of my presentation can
any of you tell which one is me yeah
this is me I was 7 years old and I was
with the fums in a poor neighborhood
where I used to leave it can you guess
why I'm so crazy about growing going
together with the socially neglected as
a matter of fact two days ago I and the
mayor of New York Eric Adams met and
drank together
and at that time we found out many
common things about our childhood
background at the time he told me his
mother said how time makes strong man I
totally agreed with him it's one of main
theme of today's lecture I
think actually today's uh theme was a
little serious isn't it so I prepared a
video clip one minute shot About
[Music]
Soul
thank you thank you for your
listen
so thank you mayor o um let me test the
microphone first can you hear me okay
okay good it's a real honor to be with
you my my name is Eric harmes I'm a
professor of anthropology here I
specialize in urbanization in Southeast
Asia and had spent a long time working
in Vietnam myself so I was very pleased
to see the interest that you have in the
developing world and and your your U
contributions to other cities um but I
wanted to ask you a question about um
your emphasis on going together with the
socially neglected one of the themes
that most people talk about when they
talk about soul is high property
prices and it's difficult to reconcile
um the question of the socially
neglected with property prices and so
one of the things that many housing
activists will talk talk about is the
need to manage property price on the
other hand often times uh those who
think about the national economy the
development of the city some of the kind
of images that we see in the video here
um will also say that well actually
managing property pric is very important
for the stability of the economic
development so I'd just like to ask you
what do you think about how to manage
the property price issue especially in
conjunction with what you were talking
about today with the social I understand
I think it's just supply and demand
issue actually for the last 10 years of
course it's another mayor's time not my
time at the time he has a kind of
political status about the real estate
housing anti Redevelopment rebuilding
the houses so because of the the policy
at the time the price of hous are
increasing and increasing day by day I
think it is very important for us to
supply enough houses so after I became
the mayor again I started to supply
enough houses through rebuilding and
Redevelopment because there is no vacant
spaces within the city profer so if we
want more supply of new houses we must
demolish old houses and instead of that
we must build some more houses speedily
that is the most important solution of
course there are so many regions of high
price of houses but this in this short
time I can't explain all the Visions
first of all the most important thing is
supply of houses and I'm making every
effort to supply the new
houses thank you I'll shift to another
question and by by the way after I ask a
few questions we'll be opening it up to
the audience for other questions as well
um another topic that one immediately
encounters when one thinks about modern
day South Korea so and modern day South
Korea as a whole is the concern about
declining fertility
rates it's very serious it's very
serious right and some some Scholars
have speculated that some of the
meteoric rise of of so like Korea's
South Korea's economy over the past year
has been related to demographic change
and in fact limiting population growth
but now people are very concerned about
the future and so how do you imagine
balancing that in in a a thoughtful
thoughtful
way it's to tough question because as
you know there is
no right answer about the the phenomenon
let's ask to young people
[Laughter]
why actually uh there are so many
regions but I think education the cost
of education is very high in this in my
country actually as I told you Koreans
are very interested in education
education is
all so they don't spare their money to
educate their
children so many Korean young people
feel that the cost of education is too
high so the first solution is the
government or sole Metropolitan
government must help them to educate
effectively
efficiently but as you know it is almost
impossible uh so we are making every
effort to help to educate their children
anyway immigration
immigration is a kind of solution it's
very sensitive issue so uh in Korea I do
not mention about
immigration it's very sensitive but
recently in our country the issue of
immigration is emerging as a
solution it's very beginning stage of
talking about immigration but it stopped
is start maybe in one year two years
many Koreans will agree with the
solution of immigrant and moreover the
foreign students but there are many
foreign students especially Southeastern
Asian countries there are so many
foreign students in Korea as I told you
there are so many universities and
colleges 54 universities so we are
considering about uh giving them better
to settle down in Soul it's very
beginning stage of talking but it starts
I think it's second solution so I'll
have one more question before I open it
up to the audience I have other
questions if it gets quiet but I doubt
it will be quiet and this great audience
um the the last topic I'd like to raise
for you you mentioned um some of the
innovations that you have for addressing
of the environmental crisis that the
globe is facing and I we I have a
colleague here at Yale Keno who's in the
school of environment and one of the big
discoveries that she's made and has been
sharing with the world is you know we
tend to imagine that cities are the
opposite of the environment right but in
fact cities themselves play a very
strong role in some of the global
climate solutions that we can have
because cities um have the capacity to
bring people together to although the
city itself may have certain ecological
challenges it can reduce environmental
footprints on a larger scale um cities
can be the the the space where one can
have very strategic design interventions
to solve climate issues um and so on and
so forth you mentioned in your talk uh
about the The Innovation with the metro
card but clearly there's other things
and one of the things that people notice
when they visit soul is they expect
expected to be only city and then they
see this kind of very interesting
integration with green space and City
space that is actually quite well done
so I wondered if you could tell our
audience about some of the successes
that you see in Soul um and also some of
some of the challenges that you you
think need to be addressed and what are
some of your ideas uh yes uh Frankly
Speaking it is very difficult job for
every mayor in the world actually this
visit to New York is for the meeting of
C40 C40 is the mayor's Forum uh in the
world to solve the climate crisis at the
steering committee when I attend the
steering committee I reported three
experiences three issues in Soul first
yes I I mentioned today the waste
separation and recycle recycling it's
very successful case
and second as I told you I introduced
the climate companion card and for your
information is for the tourist and
foreign people also it's very it will be
very useful I think and third was the
Ecom mileage system actually 10 years
ago in my first term of of mayors of
soul I started uh initiated the Ecom
mileage system as you can guess soite
citizen of Soul can reduce the the
energy and have water it will be
accumulate as a point and they can use
the point as a kind of money so it was
very successful
policy as far as I remember from 2005 to
2022 we can reduced the
CO2
CO2 about
99.2% it was very successful trial and
very successful initiative so I reported
the successful case to the mayor C40 as
you know the CO2 uh is produced in the
buildings and Transportation uh in City
especially City so ger energy buildings
are very important and low emission
vehicles are very important the two
solutions are very important in the city
because there is no factories in the
city like so so our ambitious goal is
reduce 30% of coo by
2030 70% by 2040 and
100% by
2050 you plan to be mayor that
long to see it through
yeah yes of
course yes it's anyway it's very
ambitious goal aggressive goal of Soul
Metropolitan government Frankly Speaking
yes I agree with you well thank you for
entertaining my tough questions um I
want to now open it to the audience I
believe we have microphones on either
side and if it gets quiet I have
questions but I hope I don't have to
answer ask them um I think we can start
on this side there's a person right
there uh I just want to say thank you so
much for this talk today it's it's meant
a lot um and personally I thought your
uh philosophy in terms of helping the
socially Mar the economically
marginalized very interesting and I just
wanted to ask how are you planning on
implementing that philosophy in terms of
socially marginalized groups such as
women and gender minorities in soul and
what initiatives can we look forward to
in Soul in the coming years uh for oh
sorry for women and gender
minorities I think your English is too
fast oh I'm
sorry so I need some help from it's very
sensitive
question as a matter of fact my party is
conservative
party uh of course women women's case I
10 years ago I started the policy for
the women the the initiatives name was
for women's Happiness
Project so for
instance I made the women only parking
lot in the basement and there are there
were so many policies for
women
get
it's my
answer would you like to call on people
yourself rather okay okay
yeah yes
you uh it's my great honor uh that I can
ask you a question uh I'm a post do in y
University and I'm Al father of one
daughter so uh before I coming here I'm
thinking like after like five or six
years I may go back to Korea but
nowadays is my problem because nowadays
living in Korea is too competitive like
like buying the apartment or teaching I
education I'm sorry
about in addition to that in this living
cost of K Korea is too high like like
most of Kore post do want to be a
faculty in Korea I think but the thing
is that the salary of a faculty is too
low to be a to live in
Korea so uh so I think many of many
doctor or post do would agree with me so
this would be the reason why many many
Korean want to stay here I think you are
you would be like next president
candidate or next next year
right so I really want to hear know
about your opinion and second is that
that is similar thing so in in these
days many brilliant Korea students just
want to be a doctor so another major is
kind of it's kind of neglected so do you
have solution about that because it
would be associated with by our
country's development right every if
everyone to be a doctor who who who
study about the engineering or other STS
right so my my question is simply two
things um how can you handle about our
competitive envelopment or culture
second thing is that how can you serve
those doctor origin I mean every wants
to be a doctor so how can you handle
that question can can I can I deliver
clearly anyway thank you for my
English
[Applause]
yes it's very important Cas I know
Frankly Speaking I can't say solution
clearly in this room now it's very
difficult issue so I will study about
that after this lecture I'm sorry thank
you mayor for coming and spending time
with us I'm a second year master Master
student in public policy um it's a
widely known fact that among um
selective welfare and Universal welfare
uh more than a decade ago you stood on
the side of selective welfare but in
today's slides um policies such as um
public transport policy that you're
promoting it sounds like it leans more
towards uh Universal welfare now which
makes me a bit be confused about what
your philosophy is so I would like to
ask you what's your take on it and
please do remember I'm a Korean Citizen
and I have voting
rights
for
right
understood thank you hi thank you for
your speech um I'm Lynn I'm an
undergraduate in NE College I'm also an
international student from Korea your
mayor election was the first election I
ever voted in um so this is really crazy
for me um I just had I think maybe an
easier question uh my sister recently
graduated from chungam element El school
but um you mentioned in your slides that
you were um striving for more equity in
the education system especially between
the different class social classes um
and a phenomenon that happens in Korea
is students often or families sometimes
lie about their address in order to be
zoned into a different public school and
that is very much the case with Cham
like my sister's school chungam
elementary school so I was wondering
what you were doing in order to make the
public school system more Equitable um
considering that zoning is such a a big
part of the education system actually
you are Korean but uh your English is
too
fast it's difficult but I understood
actually in Korea education is
the
there there are so many Korean reporter
at the end of the this room I should say
say we have about 5 minutes left before
we break for the this the reception
afterwards so I think we can take two
more questions we should get one from
the far back and then from this side
after that so there's a hand very
eagerly raised in the far
back
yeah thank you I'm zah I am from
Afghanistan and I am honored to be here
as a research flow in La school um
actually uh I visited seul in 2017 and
found this city a a very uh development
and beautiful city I also talked uh with
some uh men and women in seul and found
um some similarity between the structure
of the family in uh seul and in
Afghanistan also but big different uh
differences between the structure of the
society I want uh I would like to ask
about
um uh how you deal with the issue of
gender in SE in your country I mean uh
because there is a uh obvious different
uh uh you know uh there is a big
different in my Society because we are
facing gender apart apartheid in
Afghanistan but you as a developed
country um has many uh
achievement in the uh aspect of
gender did my I am clear I or I should
explain my question I want to know about
the a place of women in the structure of
the society how you share I mean your
government share the power with the men
in your
country thank
you
[Music]
for
afist
so last question I'll let you choose the
last
one hi my name is Claire and I'm an
undergraduate student a korean-american
undergraduate student at Yale um just to
build off the previous question I wanted
to ask in a more societal skill um do
you believe that the stigmatization of
feminism exists in Korea and if so what
do you think about
it
for
thank you so that brings our session to
a close I want to thank you mayor o for
joining
us thank you so
[Applause]
much